spirit of transparency can you tell us
where this 12 billion pounds in welfare
cuts is going to come from well let me
explain we've said that there's a 30
billion pound adjustment that needs to
be made and the other political parties
have voted for this too and we've said
that breaks down into 13 billion that
needs to be saved in government
departments 12 billion in welfare and 5
billion from cracking down on tax
evasion and aggressive tax avoidance and
when it comes to the welfare we've
identified for instance freezing in work
benefits like unemployment benefit for
two years to raise some of that money
but the 12 million right that the 12
billion 10 billion of which you've yet
to explain that that compares with 20
billion that was saved in the last
Parliament in this current Parliament by
this government on welfare so this is
well within the range of what we can do
if if you continue with the sort where
we put in place you know where these
cuts will fall but we know that it is
possible to make the savings in welfare
like we made we made twenty billion
dollars a route but um do you know and
you're not telling us or do you not know
that we know there will be difficult
decisions and will have to go through
every part of the welfare budget but we
believe just as we saved 20 billion in
welfare in this Parliament we will be
able to find a further 10 billion of
welfare savings in the next model let me
give you some more examples we're going
to cut the the welfare cap we put in
place saying no family should get more
than 26 thousand pounds a year in
welfare we're going to reduce that to
23,000 that's not within them we think
that if we think that is we think that's
the right thing to do we're going to say
when it comes to young people that young
people when they leave school they
should be either earning or learning
they should be doing an apprenticeship
looking at higher education they
shouldn't be able to go straight on to
unemployment benefit and Housing Benefit
it all of these things changing welfare
Jeremy isn't just about saving money you
know it's about trying to but you help
people's logic by trying to when I'm
talking about transparency and you don't
tell us what you're going to do what I
do ask yourself let me ask you